the rocky Atlantic coast of Lanzarote
Island a barren volcanic landscape and
house is painted in traditional white if
you head inland you'll find the village
of los vias and the home of Yahoo and
Oda fantasy Leon hello
welcome come on in Yaya who's Spanish
and Oda who's German met in Lanza rota
30 years ago today they rent out country
homes but this one is special it's built
largely underground this is what we call
an aji Bay an old cistern we turned it
into a small country home for centuries
the villagers stored rainwater here now
it's been turned into a holiday home
they discovered the cistern by chance
it's right next to their main house we
couldn't see how big it was
so we crawled through a hole in the
ceiling we saw that the place was half
full of water I said to my wife this is
great maybe we could build a small home
here and that's exactly what we did the
couple have divided the cistern into two
levels downstairs for living and
upstairs for sleeping they've tried to
keep the cistern pretty much as it was
we decided right away that we wouldn't
even touch the walls all we did was seal
the cracks and the result is something
that resembles a painting by a really
good artist it's wonderful don't you
think
the home is decorated with works by
local artists Yaya was born in lancer
rota and he's proud of his heritage this
dragon sculpture was created by Xavier
Ibanez the kitchen and bathroom are
located in the above-ground unit yo-yo
and Oda wanted to make sure that the
layout of this part of the house
complemented the style of the cistern
unit of course the cistern is very dark
and we decided that we wanted to provide
a contrast to that so we decided to
bring in as much light as possible
that's why there's so much glass outside
there's a small garden and a stately
palm tree in fact if it hadn't been for
the tree yeah you might not have
discovered the location at all it came
about while he was out taking photos one
day with a friend here's one of the
houses that we photographed back then
this is lost bias here you can see a
camel that's been chained to that palm
tree that wick the cistern is right next
to it but all that's left of this scene
today is the camels chains
morado El Camino
Oh des and Yaya Fanta stellen now rent
out the cistern it's a unique place to
stay in a secluded area of Lanzarote